we received calls to reports of gunshots
in Mountain Road se24
officers including armed response teams
attended with the London Ambulance
Service and the London air ambulance
and despite the efforts of the Emergency
Services two men both in their twenties
sadly died at the scene
following initial inquiries we believe
that two cars were being driven at speed
in the Walton Road area
one of the cars struck a moped before
colliding with parked vehicles
the divider with the moped is one of the
two men who died at the scene and at
this stage
there is nothing to indicate that here's
an intended target
tragically we believe he was out riding
his moped when he was caught up in this
violent incident
following the Collision an occupant of
the first car got out and made his way
down the road pursued by a male from the
second car who was in possession of a
firearm
the fleeing male was shot and also
tragically died at the scene
the gunman returns his car and drove
away
we are not confirming the identity of
the victims at this stage but officers
are confident they know who they are
and then next of kin have been informed
and will be provided with support from
specialist officers
our thoughts are with the families and
friends of the two young men who are
tragically lost their lives
this is an incredibly serious incident
an investigation is underway at PACE led
by the homicide detectives from the Met
specialist crime command
I know I share the feelings of the whole
Community when I say that I'm shocked
and sanded by this incident and I
recognize a concern it will have caused
locally and to The Wider community and
we're already working closely with our
partners to provide reassurance and
support to Residents and others that
have been affected
it is likely there will be ongoing
disruption in a local area where
detectives carry out their urgent
inquiries including the continued
closure of some roads and I would like
to thank residents for their continued
patience and cooperation
local offices will continue to patrol
the the area in the coming days talking
to Residents and being visible and
providing reassurance
I would urge anyone with any information
about this terrible incident to come
forward either to the police or
anonymously to Crime Stoppers
someone out there will have some
information or know who has been
involved
and will help us bring Justice to those
responsible
thank you
Chief superintended Colin wingrove there
from the metropolitan police giving us
an update on that shooting in Brixton
South London to a young men lost their
lives one was driving a moped and chief
superintendent Colin wingrove there
saying that they don't believe he was an
intended target he got caught up in this
violent incident and lost his life they
are appealing for information we'll have
more from our correspondent Jamal
Freeman Powell at the scene at four
o'clock